c'est un ami de quarante ans cette année
de nicolas sarkozy il le rappelle dans
son livre la france pour la vie que nous
recevons dans preuve par 3 bonsoir brice
hortefeux reçoit michel mention et merci
d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse un moment délicat
pour votre ami qui a passé et qui est
toujours actuellement dans le bureau des
juges a interrogé sur ses comptes de
campagne vous réagirez dans un instant
et vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions au cours de cette émission
d'abord face à l'hyper terrorisme moc
qui l'utilisent
manuel valls at il raison d'annoncer le
pire ou est-ce qu'il joue avec l'
angoisse des français
ensuite la primaire se transforme-t-elle
en tout sauf sarkozy on a vu un ce
week-end que les grandes manoeuvres
avaient été lancés des bras clos de la
fp vous interrogera sur ce sujet enfin
face aux crises du moment qu'ils ne
trouvent pas de solution les migrants la
désespérance des éleveurs et des
agriculteurs en france et puis également
le risque de brick site question député
européen tout à l'heure avec mes kms
l'union européenne joue tel actuellement
sa survie
nicolas sarkozy donc est entré ce matin
il était 9 heures environ dans le bureau
des juges du pôle financier
les dépenses de sa campagne de 2012 sont
au coeur des interrogations que
savait-il donc du dépassement au bas mot
dit on quelques 19 millions d'euros sur
quoi selon vous où va déboucher son
audition
bon d'abord il ya une réalité vous
employez à juste titre le terme
d'audition c'est lui il s'agit d'une
audition qui s'inscrit dans la suite
à vrai dire logique dans une suite
prévisible d'une instruction lorsque
l'on a appelé la ferme il m'a lyon c'est
la conséquence et nicolas sarkozy vous
en souvenez a constamment indiqué et
sans d'ailleurs être un ce jour démenti
à aucun moment et a toujours indiqué
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
personnellement cette société il a tout
il l'a toujours dit
la question peut enlever le détriment
des comptes 3e troisième élément à ce
jour son honnêteté et sa probité
personnelle
vous l'avez observé ne sont pas mises en
cause donc je crois que puisque vous
poser une question jeu
t vous décevoir encore pourquoi vous
décevoir pourquoi je dis ça d'air parce
que c'est la stricte vérité c'est que je
crois qu'il faut laisser la procédure se
poursuive
que la justice fasse son travail et
c'est très bien bon lui ne savait pas
que sa campagne fut aussi
inflationnistes alors qu'ils étaient au
courant et qui est responsable selon
vous a bien eus observe d'ailleurs ce
que votre affirmation qui va tout à fait
dans le sens de ce que je pense mais
enfin au delà de vous elle a été
confirmée par exemple par jean françois
copé qui a indiqué dans l'audition qui
est rendue publique d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qu'il pose toujours le
problème du secret de l'instruction en
face à ces quelque chose sur laquelle
tout le monde s'assoit sens sachant que
personne et indique que à aucun moment
enfin à aucun moment dans l'audition
jean françois copé dans ses déclarations
il n'est indiqué que nicolas sarkozy
était au courant dont françois copé
d'ailleurs confirmée alors lui n'a pas
été mis en examen il a dit aulas je suis
soulagé je n'ai plus l'épée de damoclès
au dessus de ma tête est ce que vous
croyez que cette épée de damoclès change
de tête ce soir ou demain si l'audition
ce poursuivi brice hortefeux mais je
vous dis il faut laisser la procédure se
poursuive encore une fois c'est ce qui
se déroule cette audition elle était
attendue elle était logique c'est dans
le cas d'une procédure est que moi mais
il faut attendre 40 ans est très serein
oui c'est un fâcheux les points
aujourd'hui mais enfin il était ces
jours derniers totalement serein et
concentré sur la responsabilité qui est
la sienne vous vous êtes confiant ou
inquiet quand même pour sonner vos
tracas judiciaires
écoutez je pense que comme le disait
cadre des républicains mais nouveau
cadre disais quelque part trop c'est
trop
ces jeunots moi je ne te dis pas d'autre
chose que la justice fasse son travail
trop c'est trop
non je dis pas ça je dis c'est ce qui
m'a été dit elle mais moi je vous dis
que la justice fasse son travail que le
face sereinement et ce qu'elle necid
rassure a bien dit c'est un délire de
financement illégal que de dépasser
allez les plafonds de campagne ou dit
qu'il n'a pas été averti dans le dossier
ont dit que peut-être un expert
comptable avait prévenu vous nous avez
pas entré dans le détail la comptabilité
des camps
pas un électorat parce que j'ai en moi
même d'être un génie comprend pas
toujours tout vous savez dans les
dépenses qui sont évoqués si j'ai bien
compris à des dépenses de train et une
mythique de nombreux meetings très
honnêtement il a fait à peu près en gros
le même nom de meetings que son
principal concurrent qui ait quitté
françois hollande
je crois que françois hollande indique
35-37 meeting nicolas sarkozy a indiqué
45,46 jeu de cet ordre là la première
éléments deuxième élément il faut être
un nid père spécialiste un expert mois
pour savoir si telle dépense par exemple
de transport de train doit être imputée
à la campagne d'attaqués imputées à la
famille politique
s'il y a des dépenses globales qui ne
aussi concerner les élections
législatives mais tout ceci est très
compliqué ce qui est sûr ce qui est
certain c'est que l'honnêteté et la
probité de nicolas sarkozy ne sont à
aucun moment mis en cause des niches
également ne surprend pas il met
également en avant dans son lait le fait
qu'il était président la république et
candidat donc président république très
accaparé c'est une thèse que yoo est
également bien du mal tant que je sache
c'est ce que j'ai vécu moi-même j'ai été
candidat tête de liste aux élections
européennes sur trois régions l'auvergne
ma région la région centre limousin et
un budget de campagne très honnêtement
les jeux moi je me préoccupais pas des
dépenses vous préoccupez effectivement
des recettes et à la fin de la campagne
j'ai réunis en équipes le trésorier judy
samaya pas de souci tu es tu es et tu es
sûr que tout est dans les clous oui oui
et puis voilà on paraphe un document ce
très bon j'imagine que quand on est chef
de l'état et candidat même temps ceci
est démultipliée donc voilà la légalité
encore une fois
laissons la procédure allait en à la
santé on attend la décision des juges
donc peut-être ce soir et on reviendra
sur nicolas sarkozy dans un instant avec
tes questions bien sûr sur la primaire
brice hortefeux on évoque maintenant la
menace terroriste alors que le groupe
les eagles 1 retrouve une salle
parisienne ce soir l'olympia un concert
en forme de thérapie dit le chanteur du
groupe mais l'angoissé tel selon vous
entretenu par manuel valls qui prévient
qu'il y aura d'autres attentats
d'ampleur en évoquant une guerre et
celle de l'hyper terrorisme en
l'écoutent c'était ce week-end à munich
cette vérité à nos peuples il y aura
d'autres attaques des attaques d'ampleur
c'est une certitude cette hyper
terrorisme est là pour durer
même si nous devons bien entendu le
combattre avec la plus grande
détermination
manuel valls évoqué une menace ce sans
doute supérieure à celle d'avant le 13
novembre parce que c'est déjà tenir pour
acquis des succès et des terroristes
pour venir d'abord euros
le gouvernement a t-il raison de
rappeler que la menace existe il a
raison
celle ci exige d'elles est pas récente
mais quand j'ai exercé les fonctions
mille de l'intérieur
j'ai été confronté à cette
responsabilité à ce diable devoir de
vérité trettel donc il ne faut pas être
dans le déni fois dans la vérité quelle
est la réalité aujourd'hui
pour rester sur notre pays vous avez
huit mille deux cent cinquante personnes
vivant sur le territoire français qui
sont et ce que l'on appelle radicaliser
des musulmans radicaliser et ce qui est
important
le schip tu es tu 1250 ne signifie pas
grand chose mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que 8250 c'était au 31
décembre est qu'au mois de mai et
c'était 4015 très exactement dans cette
en rites et une explosion de la menace à
ce deuxième et premier élément deuxième
élément ce qui est très important c'est
que 95% de ceux qui sont supposés
radicaliser et selon tt par des contacts
personnels ou ceux dont on parle
beaucoup du les contacts par l'internet
suite pour c'est une réalité mais 95 %
lorsqu'ils sont suivis lorsqu'ils sont
interrogés c'est ensuite d'un contact
personnel c'est un contact dans le
milieu éducatif dans le milieu
professionnel en salle de sport dans le
milieu associatif et autres donc 3e
troisième élément
ce qui est important c'est que et ce
seront des groupes très jeune puisque
20% sont déjà 2 0 aux alentours de 20
ans donc le
il y a il y à cette réalité à cela
s'ajoutent les 11500 dont on parle dont
on a parlé un peu plus d'ailleurs qui
sont les fichiers est ce qui nécessite
une attention toute particulière donc
oui le premier ministre a raison sur ce
plan mais par mon de l'est en revanche
c'est se poser la question pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'on a une politique
étrangère que jeu dont je ne conteste
pas les fondements mais en revanche je
m'interroge sur l'impréparation des
conséquences on a une politique
étrangère qui est très offensive très
offensif sur un certain de territoires
de la planète notamment très offensive
et au mali très présente désormais aussi
sur indirectement ou directement en
syrie dans le cadre d'une coalition mais
on est présent il faut pas s'étonner si
on est en pointe dans le combat contre
les extrémistes contre déj contre aqmi
enfin toutes ces nébuleuse islamiste il
est assez logique celle ci ceci ne nous
veulent pas du bien est ce que l'on a
suffisamment anticipé donc c'est bien de
dire qu'il faut être vigilant mais en
revanche c'est insuffisant que de se
limiter à cela la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence vous l'approuvez oui est ce
que vous demandez par exemple certains
de vos amis par exemple au sénat de
droite aujourd'hui d'aller plus vite
dans la constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence avec la dèche et en ma
conviction c'est que le sénat a un rôle
très important à jouer et je les
regardais der au sénat de rappeler
quelle est la nature et qu'elle doit
être l'objectif qu'elle doit être son
sont précisément sans son rôle sa
responsabilité du serait drôle
d'ailleurs la responsabilité c'est
précisément d'écrire un texte ou
invoquer la déchéance et qu'ils
reprennent ce qui avait été déclaré
d'ailleurs au mois de novembre par le
chef de l'état par le chien de la
résolution de compris pour le compromis
pour aller vite
écoutez ce fait devant le chef de l'état
aujourd'hui il fallait écouter le chef
de l'état et bien malin celui qui
comprend très exactement le fil de sa
pensée
parce que soit c'est très compliqué soit
ce serait très ficelles au choix c'est
peut-être est-ce d'ailleurs les deux
complexes et ficelles
parce que la réalité c'est qu'il ya eu
cinq ou six positions différentes
depuis le 16 novembre reconnaissez que
c'est pas d'une clarté aveuglante et
peut-être ficelles ficelles enfin pardon
à force de vouloir trop finasser il
arrive qu'on se ramasse et c'est que le
chef de l'état peut être voulez tendre
un piège à l'opposition - en quoi ça
s'est refermé sur la laïcité place elle
tout cas ce qu'ils soient n'est pas très
glorieux et ce n'est pas trés quoi mais
ils n'ont d'ailleurs pas moins que oui
moi j'appartiens à l'essai parlementaire
qui sommes favorables à la déchéance de
nationalité
et ce n'est pas parce que c'est françois
hollande qui l'a promu ou qu'il a
rappelé ou qui la reprise
exactement et bien c'est pas parce que
c'est lui qu'on doit automatiquement le
condamner ce qui compte un moment donné
c'est qu'il faut faire pour être à
l'heure à la société gens viennent vous
dire à fissel fils est l'ennemi le
patron des sénateurs socialistes didier
guillaume averti aujourd'hui les
victimes des attentats ne peuvent pas
être les otages de la primaire des
républicains est là il a raison de viser
donc ce que vous évoquez la sensibiliser
ceux qui sont opposés à la gpe françois
fillon non ce sont des propos injurieux
ce sont des propos injurieux parce que
sur un sujet aussi grave qui touche à
l'intérêt général qui concerne la
protection de nos concitoyens qui relève
de la sécurité collective le présenter
ainsi et le réduire à des compétitions
des émulations électorale c'est indigne
donc j'ai dit ce sont des propos
injurieux alors tous les cas l'état
d'urgence n'empêche pas des faits de
violence sur la voie publique jeudi à
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
on le voit en corse en ce moment où les
incidents se répètent après le match
race bastia une information judiciaire a
été ouverte après la perte de l'usagé
d'un oeil par un étudiant les nouveaux
responsables s'expriment sur ce sujet
écoutez gilles simeoni le président des
collectivités territoriales interrogé
cet après-midi par quentin calme et que
notre souci aujourd'hui notre
responsabilité c'est de tout faire pour
que l'apaisement revienne c'est ce que
nous faisons en elle
l'élu en appelant au calme et à cette
erreur de témoignages concordants qui
tendent à penser qu'il ya eu d'une part
de flashball carrément baissé ce jeune
homme et d'autre part un certain nombre
de comportements agressifs dans les
façons verbales que physiques de la part
de certains policiers
il y aurait eu ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit ce sont des témoins qui étaient
présents des insultes à caractère
raciste des allusions à la situation
politique de l'île
nous avons dit simplement que si tel
était le cas cela n'était absolument pas
alors je ne sait manier donne donc du
crédit un racisme anti corse des forces
de l'ordre comment est-ce que vous
réagissez coûté 2 de la part d'une
équipe personnalisé enfin de la part
d'une équipe qui doit maintenant
désormais diriger la collectivité
régionale dont certains de ses
dirigeants ont un passé qui honnêtement
un passé assez lourd
un passé qui ne renvoient pas aux heures
les plus glorieuses de la corse qui ont
certains font des discours encore tout
en expliquant que la france est un bon
partenaire peut jouer peut-être un peu
près le mot qui a été utilisée
franchement jeunes je prends ce qui est
dit avec ce que cela mérite quand ils
ont les la france est un pays ami
oui la france est un pays ami comme s'il
n'était pas dans la nation dans la
nation française je ne suis pas sûr qu
nettement les corses et voter pour ce
spectacle là mais ça me déçoit on avait
des slogans par exemple on a tué votre
préfère on va vous cramer sur bad
naturellement de perdre tout le monde ne
peut que condamner que condamner avec la
vision devra grâce à la fermeté comme il
l'a déjà montré encore je vais vous dire
un moment donné il faut que ceux qui
sont les responsables du gouvernement
je t'arrête les coups de menton et
agissent avec des biceps
parce que les coups de menton ça fait
trois ans qu'on a droit à sa la
république ne tolèrera pas les zones de
non-droit ça suffit aucun territoire ne
doit être très grave et très bien ça ce
sont les voir d'accord mais là ce sont
là ce sont des coups de menton un moment
donné il faut que après les coups de
menton il y aussi des faits de biceps
qui se traduise dans les faits eh bien
ce n'est pas le cas concrètement le
retour de l'ordre dans le bastia à corte
où les étudiants se réunissent ce soir
encore bien sûr mais pas simplement
pourquoi vous parlez de simplement de
aujourd'hui mais moi j'ai honte de ce
qui se passe sur l'ensemble du
territoire français dont la corse fait
partie je vous dis aux jeunes si vous
regardez ce qui se passe depuis 2012
si vous regardez les résultats de la
lutte contre la délinquance je vous
apercevez que depuis 2012 tous les
grands agrégats tous les grandes mains
de la délinquance que ce soit les
violences aux personnes
les a tant fait c'est à dire les
atteintes à gré et et à l'intégrité
physique les atteintes aux biens les
escroqueries et ainsi de suite
le taux d'élucidation tout ceci se
détériore depuis 2012 et je mets au défi
quelques responsables connaissance et
sujet de me démontrer le contraire
et vous savez il n'y a pas de mystère de
2002 à 2011
la délinquance a reculé dans notre pays
pas suffisamment part assez fortement
pas sans doute partout mais c'est comme
ça et depuis 2002 c'est ça la réalité ça
s'est dégradé
alors vous voulez du biceps à ça à
propos du remaniement manuel valls a
déclaré hier soir que son gouvernement
remanié était cohérent et il va réformer
jusqu'au bout voilà de bonnes vacances
et oui j'y croyais et je crois ou ai je
crois aux bonnes intentions derrière moi
je crois plutôt à la bonne volonté je
pense à l'actuel ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeau je crois tout à fait à sa
la volonté qui est la sienne de faire au
mieux pour la sécurité de nos
consciences
le seul problème c'est que ça traduit
absolument pas dans les faits et vous
prenez l'exemple du gouvernement qu'est
ce que c'est cette à revenir
régulièrement qu'elle on recycle recycle
des personnalités qui ont été battus une
fois battu deux fois et au sénat et la
présidente du conseil départemental est
institué dans lequel on re plâtre c'est
à dire qu'on met des écologistes qui
avaient disparu et puis on les remet
dans le jeu et ainsi de suite
on va écouter donc ça suffit pas à
démontrer une cohérence
franchement et je l'appelle j'espère
ailleurs la cohérence à l'heure chez
vous par votre quand on va en parler
tout de suite on a parlé de la primaire
de la droite et du centre ce week-end on
a vu nicolas sarkozy
snobé par ses rivaux c'est bien ce qui
s'est passé alors pas du tout est ce le
début des bois d'un démenti faisait
pouvoir apporter un démenti à ces faits
ah ça y est c'est fait et est au début
d'un tout sauf sarkozy extraits avant
d'accueillir deborah claude de ce qui
s'est passé ce week-end en écoute
l'ancien chef de l'état et puis alain
juppé alors vous allez voir si ces snobs
et ou pas le texte que je vais vous
présenter m'engage engage la direction
notre mouvement est naturellement ce
projet collectif ambitieux si vous
voulez qu'ils aient du sens il engagera
notre mouvement et chacun de ses membres
n'ont certainement pas donc certainement
pas sans sagna primaire et c'est très
important de réussir les primaires c'est
de nos plans aux primaires nous
prendrons présidentielle voilà deborah
claude devait rejoindre soit là à brice
hortefeux sur la primaire alors vous
avez déjà répondu non à la première
pourtant alain juppé n'était pas
dimanche françois fillon n'était pas non
plus présent
donc pour vous le discours n'a pas été
snobé dimanche au conseil national
là vous faites vous décrivez une vision
pas par le grand bout de la lorgnette 1
par le tout petit conseil n'assurer que
s'est-il passé ce d'un une instance qui
rassemble les principaux cadres locaux
de notre famille politique d'avoir
premiers éléments et ses cadres ses
cadres ont été élus il ya une quinzaine
de jours dans votre précipitation vous
avez oublié de rappeler que cela s'était
déroulé dans de très bonnes conditions
qu'il n'y avait pas de contentieux août
caisse ils ont même dit vous incarnez
tout ça tout ça ça s'est très bien passé
deuxième élément vous évoquez les
candidats à la primaire de bon ses
portes très gentil pour tous les autres
et pour ça notre famille politique qui
étaient là nous sommes au sénat je
trouve pas ça très habile de votre part
de ne pas compter parmi les vraies
personnalités le deuxième personnage de
l'état
oui le deuxième personnage de l'état
ça vous a visiblement échappé ce qui est
inquiétant mais il était là à la
primaire
c'est libre avoue ne pas vous intéresser
aux plaisirs du sénat ce n'est pas mon
cas rentrait j'y attache un grand prix
donc le président du sénat était là la
plupart des responsables étaient
imposées si c'est ce que vous êtes entré
jeu ensuite factuellement vous
m'expliquer que les candidats imprimés
n'était pas là ils sont tous venus
samedi
oui samedi 12 et dimanche il avait ce
matin c'était passé c'était le dimanche
c'était pas toute la journée donc pardon
de vous dire vous pouvez prendre c'est
avec le sourire mais comme vous évoquer
ces sujets sérieusement sans sourire
donc je voulais tout le monde a
travaillé de constater de reconnaître
qu'ils sont tous c'est que l'on a sur le
fond nicolas sarkozy a prononcé un
discours en faveur d'une démarche
collective mais on vient bien on voit
bien que ça fait tiquer les rivaux de la
primaire écouter ils ne veulent pas se
sentir engagé par ce travail collectif
vous allez réseau répondez vous avez
raison et je me tourne pas simplement
vers vous parce qu'il faut aussi que je
vous donne raison si je ne serai pas
sympathique de l'appareil ajuste est
malemenée donc la réalité elle est très
simple c'est qu'effectivement la
responsabilité n'est pas les mêmes selon
les uns des autres
les candidats à la primaire ils ont
comme préoccupation leur avenir dans
cette campagne pour la primaire nicolas
sarkozy sa responsabilité est totalement
différente
elle est deux fois différente la
première c'est que et pèse sur lui la
responsabilité de notre famille
politique
je vous rappelle que il a il n'est pas
là par le fruit du hasard
ça peut déplaire il n'est pas là par
l'opération du saint-esprit même si
celui ci peut aider il est là parce
qu'il a été élu c'est pas une
auto-proclamation il est là parce qu'il
a été élu élu très largement puisque il
a été élu avec le double de voix de
celui qui était son concurrent le plus
direct le doubs c'est vous dire comme le
succès a été large et donc il a sur ses
épaules et donc sa responsabilité sur
les épaules c'est celle net de
l'ensemble de notre famille qui était
fracturée et il a réussi
il a mis autour de la table tous ceux
qui voulaient la renverser c'est vrai
que ça c'est le premier élément est
deuxième élément concernant le prochain
oui pardonnez moi il dit quelque chose
qui me paraît de bon sens
c'est qu'une famille politique qui n'a
pas un projet collectif
franchement il faut qu'elle renonce donc
lui sa responsabilité alors c'est
peut-être pas son bénéfice personnel
alors j'espère certainement pour la
cause collective et la façon de mettre
sur la table c'est de mettre sur la
table un projet qui soit un projet
collectif rsa seule préoccupation c'est
le rassemblement on peut se demander en
même temps à quoi ça sert le parti quand
il ya des primaires et que chacun fait
son projet dans son coin et qu'alain
juppé ne dit pas je vais aller piocher
dans le corpus du parti ce qui a été
préparé quand les ceux qui préfèrent
vendée démarche individuelle et
personnelle c'est leur droit mais c'est
un choix du passé de la broye c'est leur
choix c'est leur responsabilité nous
autour de nicolas sarkozy nous avons une
préoccupation collective et c'est vrai
que nous voulons mettre sur la table un
projet qui est un projet fort et
peut-être qu'il reviendra ton un projet
fort et ce projet fort si des candidats
veulent eux y rajoutait des choses
qu'ils le fassent ils veulent en
retrancher c'est naturellement leurs
droits mais nous au tour de nicolas
sarkozy a raison de le dire c'est de ne
pas penser aujourd'hui exclusivement à
lui mais de penser à l'intérêt collectif
séné je pense que ce week-end c'est pour
ça que je pense que c'était une réunion
et une rencontre utile
je pense que ce week-end ça en a été la
démonstration et en même temps c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu l'impression qu'il
est affaibli
on se dit à des candidats aux primaires
qui commencent à s'aligner parce que là
on a plusieurs projets on a un nouveau
candidat puis dimanche soir jean
françois copé de nouveaux projets qui
vont arriver c'est c'est difficile comme
lâcher ce qu'il a et est ce que c'est
pas une erreur de revenir à la tête du
parti
je pars c'est l'occase là j'aurai
beaucoup de choses à dire pardon parce
que vous évoquez beaucoup tél
premièrement oui vous avez la raison sur
un point la question de son retour de
son engagement à la tête de notre
famille politique c'est une vraie
question je fais partie de ceux qui ont
ardemment milité peut-être pas
d'ailleurs dans l'intérêt personnel de
nicolas sarkozy
mais notre famille qui porte des valeurs
qui affiche des convictions qui a des
idées à défendre était pardon de lire en
voie de déstructuration peut-être même
d'ailleurs de disparition et s'il ne
s'était pas engagé s'il n'avait pas
construit
il reconstruit cette famille politique
sans doute serait ton aujourd'hui dans
une toute autre hypothèse accola l'ordre
pour l'élection présidentielle pas de
doutes sur le retour de la thèse du
parent bien sûr à 2015 ça a été l'année
de la reconstruction et du rassemblement
et 2016
ça doit être l'année de l'authenticité
et de la clarté dans les choix
et bien c'est précisément le le chemin
que nous que nous empruntons aujourd'hui
alors deuxième point si vous le
permettez pas ce que vous dites est ce
que je dois pas affaibli moi je viens je
reviens sur ce point voilà nicolas
sarkozy qui écrit un livre dont on sait
ce soir d'ailleurs que il tangente les
135 mille exemplaires c'est un énorme
succès d'ailleurs regardez le traitement
particulier qui réservait à nicolas
sarkozy puisque c'est le seul auteur je
connais pour lequel on nous fait un
sondage auprès des français pour savoir
s'il voudrait acheter et la tue 10 %
répondent oui il y en a certains
certainement un progrès certain mais pas
vous qui a dit qu'il n'y a que 10 %
c'est en fait considérable c'est déjà
presque du jamais vu à ce point la borne
est faite premiers éléments il ya ceux
là préfèrent montre quoi aussi pourquoi
ça prouve qu'il ya une attente et qu'il
est aussi porteur d'espoir et que l'on
attendait aussi sa part de vérité parce
que ce livre c'est un exercice de vérité
c'est une démonstration ci d'humilité
beaucoup de regrets dans beaucoup de
regrets volonté de simple il n'y a pas
non c'est sauver le blabla que j'ai
entendue dès les années 2012 sur le
thème harry faudrait qu'ils fassent son
bilan son neveu à petit vers le devoir
d'inventaire et à l'époque je disais
écouter s'il y en a un qui doit le faire
ce sera lui
parce que si vous pensez qu'il n'est pas
capable de comprendre ce qui a été
engagé ce qui a été initié ce qui a été
achevé ce qui n'a pas réussi
franchement alors pour vous laisser mais
l'exemple
précisément d employer des mots j'étais
sûr que vous alliez les ut deuxième
élément on parle de la déchéance de
nationalité il ya quelques instants
alors avant c'était sa ligne est
contestée institude pas du tout regardez
ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale précisément ce qu'il a défendu
c'est ce qui a été adopté par la
majorité des députés républicains donc
sa ligne a été suivi troisième élément
les sondages est effectivement vous en
parlait beaucoup des sondages mais rien
une chose qui me frappe c'est que quand
les sondages sont mauvais sache que vous
dire qu'on appelle est ce que voulait
réagir monsieur hortefeux est ce que
vous pensez pas que sk ainsi de suite là
ça fait trois sondages consécutifs
trois sondages consécutifs en trois
jours un petit bérénice au sima vous
demandez leur a posé le canon d'âge ce
week end je croise et opinionway qui
effectivement est un peu plus favorable
à une icône à 3 alors les deux autres
n'ont échappé il y en a un ce soir
alors j'ai peur quand j'ai pris
connaissance en am3 consécutifs et donc
et si vous avez cure et qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est le signe de feu si c'était
l'inversé qu'est-ce que vous nous pose
la question qu'est ce qu'on fait je
crois deviner mois à vrai dire parce que
c'était une bonne dynamique a été
enclenchée aussi par le livre est écouté
oui le livre sa présence sa volonté d'
écoute ses déplacements qu'ils essayent
de faire sans caméra sans corte un site
8 c'est pas toujours simple est
d'ailleurs un des côtés sympathie mais
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il essaie de
faire en prenant le temps du dialogue en
allant à la rencontre
il en à dire la conviction que les gens
que les personnes les français nos
concitoyens qu'ils rencontrent c'est
bien éloignée du petit milieu du petit
microcosme parisien ça c'est sûr il en
revient avec cette conviction là mais
c'est vrai que tous ces éléments ce sont
des pierres qui s'est dit qu'ils
s'ajoutent les unes aux autres est ce
que vous voyez sur à la maison il faut
plusieurs pierres est ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy j'ai envie
de dire comme jacques chirac fait battus
dans les sondages en décembre 94 et les
cinq mois plus tard est ce que vous
faites
le parallèle l'analogie engagés aux
côtés d'edouard balladur oui et ça me
rappelle des souvenirs j'ai eu et
notamment la une du monde la semaine
dernière et je me suis elle a eu du
monde qui était à peu près la même avec
les doigts balladur dans les années 94
oui ça c'est vrai c'est une
innovation factuel je n'en tire pas
c'était sûrement juppé alors là je n'en
tire pas d'autre conclusion mais
effectivement c'est faux bien avoir
savoir que avant si on n'achète pas
toujours très confortable mais en
revanche ça vous permet d'accumuler un
certain nombre de souvenirs sur le
calendrier de la candidature puisque là
il ya une certaine dynamique est ce que
vous êtes partisan d' accélérer un petit
peu là quand enfin la candidature
éventuelle de nicolas sarkozy dont on
pensait qu'elle arriverait plus tôt
après l'été est-ce qu'elle devrait
arriver avant sachant qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui déclarent ces
derniers jours moi je ne sais pas
quelles sont ses intentions
je ne pars définition que je ne connais
pas le calendrier de ses intentions ce
que je sais c'est que je suis convaincu
c'est que sa candidature sera utile ou
serait utile puisque je ne sais pas que
sa candidature serait utile non pas
simplement à notre famille politique non
pas simplement à l'opposition mais
serait utile à notre pays
mais ça j'en suis quand même si lui dis
il faut faire attention à pas faire le
match de trop
il l'a dit lors d'une émission politique
ça bien sûr mais si son tempérament
sportif sans doute elle son tempérament
il le répète dans son livre abondamment
c'est d'être toujours optimiste donc
vous ne le voyez pas décourager par
d'autres mauvais sondages ou d'autres
mauvais indicateurs en tout cas le
succès de ses rivaux dans les sondages
eux aussi brice hortefeux connaissez la
formule d'alain le pessimisme est
question de tempérament l'optimisme
affaire de volonté et donc oui nous
avons la volonté d'être optimiste pour
notre pays d'être optimiste pour nos
concitoyens d'être optimiste concernant
le rôle de la france non seulement en
europe je suis député européen je
constate chaque jour sa dégradation
mais dans le monde vont donc oui nous
avons la volonté d'être est immense
alors 130 mille acheteurs de son livre
mais vous espérez quand même vous aussi
peut-être 3 million de votants à la
primaire
là il ya une marche c'est le chiffre que
vous aimeriez atteindre 1 vous souhaite
lors de cette primaire on souhaite qu'il
y ait le maximum de par le maximum en
nous avons
un comité qui travaille sur ce sujet qui
se réunit d'ailleurs encore je crois
d'ailleurs demain après midi au sénat
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait des règles
qui soient des règles claires
ça s'est déroulé d'ailleurs je le dis
dans un climat très détendu toujours
deux points de détails mais déroulé dans
un climat détendu et responsable avec la
volonté de permettre aux français de
s'exprimer le moment venu alors et
d'exprimer leur choix parmi les
dernières prises de position il à celle
de jean-pierre raffarin je vous propose
de l'écouter donc il a annoncé qu'ils
voteraient lui alain juppé on l'écouté
pivot réagissent et brice hortefeux j'ai
choisi et de m'engager pour alain juppé
je pense qu'il incarne le projet
politique auquel je crois
je partage avec lui une ligne politique
depuis la première fois où j'étais
candidat aux élections européennes avec
lui c'était en 89
on a toujours partagé la même ligne
politique depuis donc 7 pour moi un
engagement naturel sur la ligne
politique est une évidence et une
évidence parce que la personnalité est
forte
fiables et fidèles alors un éminent
cemac sénateurs comme monsieur larcher a
pris position qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
mais c'est une position qui est assez
logique jean pierre raffarin derrière la
rapée connais alain juppé depuis qu'il
exerce des responsabilités dans les
années 80 il faut voir si l'un sans
doute dans le prolongement de cette
époque ne s'était plus aligné une prise
de position qui a surpris ce week-end
c'est celle de de luc chatel à nouveau
président du conseil national et qui a
présenté ainsi son parti des
républicains on l'écouté l'a également
vous allez pouvoir me dire si vous
l'approuvez sur toute la ligne
les républicains doivent être le propre
parti du principe d'innovation plus que
du principe de précaution
le parti du gaz de schiste le parti des
ogm
le parti des pinots tech g7 intime
conviction
vous êtes du parti des biotech je crois
qu'il ya des choses que je crois ce que
voulait dire ce qu'a voulu dire luc
chatel parce que j'en ai reparlé après
et c'est que nous devons être
effectivement aussi le parti de
l'innovation et que sans doute au
principe de précaution
devait-on avoir en tête le principe de
responsabilité c'est cela qui est voulu
dire avec ses mots et son esprit libre
et auprès de l'intéressé quelque sorte
et saint brice hortefeux on a parlé
éventuellement des doutes nicolas
sarkozy où il ira jusqu'au bout c'est
votre conviction est que le devis cécile
votre compte mon souhait c'est mon
souhait après c'est sa responsabilité
c'est une responsabilité très
personnelle comme vous l'avez dit c'est
pas l'environnement s'est passé proche
et passera la partie c'est une décision
personnelle et nicolas sarkozy a la
capacité franchement à prendre des
décisions perso je voulais vous poser la
question à propos de françois hollande
est ce qu'il lui se représentera selon
vous est le contexte autour de sa
présidence papa mais la réalité de la
situation de notre pays sans doute on
s'en rend pas compte
c'est que c'est un désastre la vérité
malheureusement c'est cela c'est un
désastre le plan de l'emploi
ce que comme vous savez nous avons un
taux de chômage qui est en était le
double le double sens pour cent de plus
que nos principaux partenaires on est à
plus de disto principaux partenaires et
c'est pas espagnol ils sont très élevés
mais ils baissent et le royaume uni qui
est à 5
l'allemagne qui est un quatre et demi je
pense pas des états unis qui veut mais
meilleurs sont à 5 et chez moi passer la
main échec sur le plan de la fiscalité
nous avons aujourd'hui une fiscalité
totalement confiscatoire et on a prélevé
cela a été dit d'ailleurs par nicolas
sarkozy on a prélevé près de 50
milliards
ces dernières années sur les ménages et
sur les entreprises moi je suis pas par
des principes je suis pas hostile à
l'effort mais encore faut-il que cet
effort et aboutisse à un progrès par
ailleurs tandis que là on a prélevé on a
prévu massivement sur les entreprises et
sur les français sans que cela ne
contribue à l'eau à alléger nos déficits
dont nous avons nous un déficit qui est
de 70 milliards les éléments les
allemands en excédent de 12 milliards
c'est pas normal que notre principal
partenaire et françois cette situation
lui comme c'est un désastre
et comme la politique qui est menée
aujourd'hui est un désastre je suis pas
sûr que celui qui a le principal
responsable du désastre
soit le mieux placé pour
nous offrir un rebond franchement ça
serait pas très cohérent si je vous
disais ça merci deborah mickaël zeze de
public sénat arrive pour la troisième
partie de l'émission restera te fais
pour évoquer les grands dossiers
européens les migrants les difficultés
des éleveurs et des agriculteurs
français qui jouent leur avenir on le
sait et puis également le risque du
départ de la grande bretagne au point
que l'on pose donc la question que l'on
vous la pose de l'union européenne qui
ne trouvent pas donc toutes les
solutions joue-t-elle sa survie à propos
des migrants manuel valls a pris l'exact
contre-pied dans gala merkel s'étaient
également ce week-end en s'exprimant en
allemagne en l'écoutent en france n'a
pas fait d'appel n'a pas fait un appel
pour accueillir des centaines de
milliers de migrants et de réfugiés
mais jugeant pas l'allemagne nous sommes
solidaires de l'allemagne dans ces
conditions très difficiles mais j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
l'europe la france et donc l'allemagne
ne pourront pas accueillir tous les
réfugiés tous les demandeurs d'asile qui
viennent des conflits comme la syrie
bonsoir michael st michel
vous savez ça te faire invitant soir est
ce que c'est la politique des coups de
marteau que man oui c'est très
exactement la réflexion je me faisais en
regardant ces images vous donne un
exemple très simple ils ont peut pas
accueillir tout le monde tout le monde
peut pas rester en vente ou non peut pas
venir en france est instituée moyennant
quoi vous dites moi là alors il ya des
mesures qui ont été prises par ce manuel
valls forte
oui et 1 et qui a été prise si la
circulaire de novembre 2012
circulaire valent ce qu'on appelle du
nom de son auteur
circuit 1 22 novembre 2012 qui est ce
qu'elle est la conséquence c'est abouti
à la régularisation massive de
clandestins qui est très exactement une
augmentation de 52% par rapport à
l'année précédente
finalement internet oui mais ça ce sont
les mots je vous donne moi la réalité
c'est pour ça que je vous encourage les
uns et les autres a bien travaillé
derrière les mots la réalité vous dites
coups de menton vous avez raison et moi
je vous répond concrètement
concrètement c'était la circulaire
novembre 2012 + 50 de régularisation
clandestins à 9,6 en temps alors
attendez le sujet des migrations c'est
un sujet majeur
c'est un sujet essentiel j'ai exercé des
responsabilités dans ce domaine et je
sais que c'est très extrêmement sensible
pourquoi parce que c'est pas ce ne sont
pas des statistiques ce sont pas
simplement des chiffons on touche à la
personne humaine
donc il faut appréhender cela avec
raison mais quand vous avez le propres
prévisions de la commission européenne
monsieur timmermans savez c'est pas un
horrible le fasciste sanguinaire c'est
pas ça est vrai quand vous avez le franc
timmermans qui explique que 60 % des
étrangers qui se présentent à la
frontière ne relève absolument pas du
droit d'asile
absolument j'ai toujours qu'il vient
donc trop tristes ils vous diraient oui
mais oui mais le problème c'est que le
plomb le fais pas je vous le dis mais ça
c'est pas des mots ce que je vous dis ce
sont des réalités
nous savons aujourd'hui parce que avec
retard et c'est ce que je regrette
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
retard et le retard permet le déni nous
savons aujourd'hui que les entrées qui
se sont passés en grèce pour celle ci il
n'y a eu jusqu'à décembre 2015 contre 8
et 23 % des empreintes digitales qui ont
été prises qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que 92% de 2,77 à 92% des personnes qui
rentrent par la turquie on ne sait pas
qui est ce on on ne sait pas ce qu'elles
font et on ne sait pas où elles vont
hélas dans croyez moi bien sûr qu'il y
avait effectivement des apprentis
terroristes vous savez s'est pas alarmé
que de le dire cela et donc alors justin
pas tout à fait complet que les grecs
ont expliqué ça c'est miraculeux qu'ils
ont expliqué à la commission européenne
que fin janvier il était je crois alors
de 80% des prises d'empreintes digitales
ce progrès est certes encourageant mais
peut-être sujet à caution vous savez
qu'il ya un mécanisme européen qui fait
qu'on peut mettre des réfugiés un peu
partout en europe dans tous les pays
d'europe
et ongs et la merkel en a reçu plus près
d'un million françois hollande
visiblement maintenant serait contre ce
mécanisme en tout cas sur nos temps
manuel valls la pole la petite française
a changé dans cette matière alors qu'il
était courant septembre
et là vous salue et peut-être l'action
d'abord la commission européenne nous
connaissez vous êtes un spécialiste est
question à une commission européenne
avait annoncé qu'ils auraient 560000
relocalisation en quelque sorte
vous savez quand il y en a eu sur les
160 milles aller des 8 joueurs 561 sur
170 561 ya eu joueurs peut-être un petit
peu plus aujourd'hui et il s'en sert
comme que je voulais donc dur mais je
veux dire que la commission que l'europe
là dessus ça ne marche pas deuxième
élément oui vous avez raison la
politique français c'est une politique
de gribouille sur ce sujet on y comprend
strictement rien c'est comme elle c'est
comme c'est comme pour la déchéance de
national la nationalité on a des
affirmations d'un côté qui sont
démenties le lendemain si aujourd'hui un
français qu'il comprend qu'il est la
politique menée par notre gouvernement
en matière d'immigration il est très
fort en tout cas il faut le faire venir
pour l'inviter faut faire beaucoup de
choses parce que c'est rigoureusement en
avance sur la réparation des migrants
est ce que vous êtes contre comme manuel
valls donc un système permanent de
répartition comme le veulent à l'europe
je dis une chose simple c'est que
concernant notre pays bien sûr il faut
lutter contre les filières premiers
éléments
deuxième élément bien sûr il faut lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
je vous rappelle qu'à l'échelon européen
l'année dernière on en fait le dernier
chiffre connu ciel 2014
c'est une autre d'autres dimensions il y
a eu 460 mille décisions de reconduite
dans 421 milles décisions de reconduite
il y en a cent soixante mille seulement
qui ont été appliquées donc premier
petit français parce que petit français
c'est aussi la politique européenne dont
un lutter contre les filières deux bien
sûr lutter contre l'immigration illégale
on ne vient pas en europe et on ne vient
pas en france si on n'y est pas
autorisée si on vient sans y être
autorisées on a vocation à être
reconduit dans son pays d'origine
a fortiori quand ce ne sont pas des
vrais demandeurs
asile le vice président de la commission
européenne ce n'est pas moi a donné ses
lois et troisièmement je vous le dis je
le dis aussi très calmement je suis très
sérieusement je lis très pondéré mans il
faut aussi dans notre pays faire
diminuer l'immigration légale
nous ne sommes pas l'allemagne
l'allemagne un taux de natalité qui est
de 20 37 c'est elle que le
renouvellement des générations n'est pas
assurée l'allemagne va avoir une pénurie
d'emploi avant 2020 qui touchera un
million huit cent mille postes ce n'est
pas le cas dans notre pays donc les
besoins de l'allemagne ne sont pas les
mêmes tout ceci pour dire quoi c'est
qu'à titre personnel en matière de
construction européenne je ne suis pas
pour que le système qui permet un
étranger arrivant sur un pays du
européens puissent se promener dans
toute l'europe sous prétexte qu'il a eu
un visa donc je suis pour que chaque
pays décide d'accueillir qui il souhaite
quels sont ses besoins
quelles sont ses volontés mais pas que
cela donne automatiquement et
mécaniquement le droit de se planter sa
saison va y revenir sur schengen
2 oui oui mais ça va pas derrière quoi
que ce soit écoutée chez mia même si
vous réécrivez schengen schengen pour
rappeler c'est un traité signé en 1985
qui permet un citoyen pénétrant dans le
territoire schengen d'aller sur la
totalité des autres territoires avec un
titre donc légale le sien le problème
schengen et je comprends pas pourquoi
personne franchement de leur appel c'est
que schengen ça a été signé en 1985 à
cinq pays
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 26 22 pays
européens dans 22 pays membres de
l'union européenne et quatre à
l'extérieur la norvège la suède la
suisse ainsi tu dois donc un traité
signé à 5
pardon s'il n'est pas vécue de la même
manière quand tout d'un coup il doit
s'appliquer à 26 et nous assistons
effectivement vous règles de schengen
ont failli alors vous semblez demander
plus d'exigences pour les
migrants et les réfugiés qui sont
accueillis sur le sol national et
laurent wauquiez a été très applaudi ce
week-end en évoquant cette question il a
évoqué la défense de la république en
l'écoutent la france de retour c'est un
pays qui ne sens pas de nature la france
de retour ce n'est pas à la république
de s'adapter aux étrangers c'est aux
étrangers de s'adapter à la république
ouais il va falloir quand même laurent
wauquiez il dit même aussi qu'il faut
durcir le droit à l'acquisition de la
nationalité française il dit c'est
l'auberge espagnole vous partagez
surnommait alors il ya plusieurs sujets
première le sujet et surtout venez vous
partager l'avis de laurent wauquiez qui
a dû suivre sur visage et pas sur
l'accès nationalité je pense exactement
un jour d'ailleurs nous avions diminué
les conditions d'accès à la nationalité
le gouvernement l'a aussi expliquer une
politique très faible l'acquisition à
nationalité augmente
il a une politique très ferme les
demandes d'asile augmentent de 22 % et
donc non celle inverse de ce que fait ce
que dit le gouvernement ce qu'il fait si
le contraire de ce qu'il dit est donc
l'acquisition à nationalité oui bien sûr
il faut revoir les conditions et les
critères d'accès il faut revoir les
conditions et critères du regroupement
familial
il faut que le temps pour bénéficier du
roman familial soit augmentée il faut
revoir les possibilités comme ça se
fédèrent dans un certain nombre de pays
la france 9 hélas ce ne serait pas
pionnière sur ce sujet et comme ça se
fait un certain nombre de pays il faut
revoir les conditions d'accès à
l'ensemble des prestations sociales
si un travailleur est en situation
légale sur notre sur notre territoire et
contribuer comme tous les citoyens
français la même manière par ses
cotisations sociales fiscales l'institut
il doit naturellement avoir les mêmes
droits
naturellement simplement s'il n'y
contribue pas et bien peu avant d'avoir
accès aux prestations sociales
il faut effectivement qu' un certain
délai ce qui est pratiqué dans un
certain nombre de pays brice hortefeux
je voudrais vous parler de calais de ce
qui se passe à calais à l'état veut
accélérer le démantèlement de ce qu'on
appelle la jungle détruire ça va régler
quoi
sur calais franchement là aussi je
trouve qu'on est d'une complaisance et
calais il y avait 600 700 personnes dans
les années 2000 s'est monté précisément
à plus de 2000 il a été décidé par
nicolas sarkozy de démanteler calais et
cela fut non seulement 10 mai fut fait
aujourd'hui on en est à 6 à 7000 la
presse le ministre de l'intérieur lundi
que ça va baisser
on en est à 6 à 7000 une partie très
importante de cette population refuse de
demander le droit d'asile
pourquoi parce qu'on veut ans devait
partir de l'onglet oui il refuse de
demander en attendant ils sont à calais
oui mais attendez
il refuse de demander l'asile c'est à
dire qu'ils sont sur le territoire de
manière inégale et refuse de s'inscrire
dans les règles qui leur permettrait de
bénéficier précisément du droit d'asile
parce que ils ne veulent pas vous venez
de l'intérieur aujourd'hui vous feriez
quoi et je démontrerai mais je
démantèlerait sens à la mode les veaux à
100% mais je démentirai bien sûr tant il
faut pas être caricatural qu'est ce que
ça veut dire démantelé ça veut dire
faire partir ceux qui n'ont rien à faire
et vous les envoyer aux mêmes et ils
repartent chez eux s'ils ne sont pas de
demandeurs d'asile c'est quoi alors des
demandeurs économique va si ce sont des
noirs de l'économie qui a pas d' espaces
deuxième élément tout c'est le premier
principe deuxième principe c'est
naturellement bien sûr et je ne doute
pas là aussi de la volonté du
gouvernement et du ministre sur ce sujet
mais ce qui compte c'est d'arriver les
résultats bien sûr qu'il faut engager un
nouveau dialogue avec le royaume uni
parce que ce sont des gens et c'est ce
que moi que j'avais pertes en raison de
désaccords et xavier bertand a
parfaitement raison parce que si ce sont
des gens sains qui ne veulent pas le
droit de bénéficier du droit d'asile ou
qui ne veulent pas déposer de demande du
droit d'asile et qui veulent aller en
angleterre il faut qu'il y ait une
compensation à la fumée alain juppé ça
fait deux fois qu'il va sur place il ya
quinze jours il est encore aujourd'hui
et xavier bertrand françois fillon va y
aller
début mars d'après ce qu'on sait et j'ai
été enquêtés du côté de nicolas sarkozy
rien n'est prévu vous trouvez ça normal
pas de déplacement sur place je sais pas
quelle enquête sur vous êtes quelques
années mais je ne vais pas m'en faire la
différence peut-être que certains
découvrent calais nicolas sarkozy est
allé
vous en souvenez certainement parce que
vous n'êtes pas si jeune que cela
certainement il est allé à plusieurs
reprises et si l'on découvre qu'elle est
et s'il ya quelqu'un qui a agi sur cet
espace qui est un espace indigne c'est
bien nicolas sarkozy on parle de la
crise agricole peut-être maintenant
déchets pour les dernières minutes de
l'émission stéphane le foll étaient hier
dans une grande réunion à vaucelles
je vous propose d'écouter ce que disent
et stéphane le foll et puis il faut
poser une petite question juste après un
conseil ou sur la base d'une mémorandum
français à la demande française
un débat a eu lieu qui fixe aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de constats communs et
qui en tout cas a fait bouger les lignes
sur l'appréciation qu'on doit avoir de
la situation sur le fait d'ailleurs que
cette situation avec cette croissance de
la production et cet excès d'offre que
nous avons dans l'est dans le port et
j'oublie pas pour ce qui concerne la
france la viande bovine des mesures
spécifiques devront être mises en oeuvre
à l'échelle européenne
alors la commission européenne n'a pas
débloqué d'argent visiblement
l'allemagne est contre le fait qu'on
débloque sud de l'argent supplémentaire
est-ce que selon vous c'est un nouvel
affrontement qu'on risque d'avoir entre
la france et l'allemagne
première observation je suis très
prudent sur les personnes enfin le
commissaire européen dans d'une
présentation devant la commission
agriculture du parlement européen a
regretté un peu l'absence française dans
les instances européennes
c'était il ya quelques ce que voulait
dire c'était quelques semaines vous
rappelle je vous rapporte ce que m'ont
dit michel dantin michel grente absence
française dans les instances européennes
et la commission jours à peine ce que
m'ont dit michel dantin député européen
angélique delahaye déplorions fait
présentement nous ont regretté ses skis
et si vous savez c'est la première fois
fait pour vous c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de la construction
la première fois qu'il n'y a pas un
français au cabinet du commissaire
européen chargé de la vie à qui la faute
en tout cas le jeu j'en suis au constat
la responsabilité est ce que la france
n'a pas suffisamment pesé est ce que la
france ne s'est pas suffisamment fait
entendre c'est ce que je pense françois
hollande qui a forcément assez pesé
cassé je constate je construis je
voudrais apporter ma réponse je constate
qu'il n'y a pas de france est première
danly sur la construction européenne au
sein du cabinet du commissaire d'état
chargé de ce succès permet pas de peser
sur les négociations tout casser c'est
certainement handicap
certainement deuxièmement la situation
française vous la connaissez moi je suis
d'une région d'élevage
le prix du lait aujourd'hui le litre est
à zéro euro
28 les agriculteurs voudrait 0,34 mais
en tout cas ce qui est une certitude
c'est que ce n'est pas à ce n'est pas
rentable
ce n'est pas équilibré à moins de 0 30
voilà la réalité relève ses prix
d'intervention
il faut un très important pour le marché
il faut il faut pas seulement de
l'avenir il faut moins de tati lionisme
fiscale et normatif déjà on commencerait
par cela ça serait une très bonne
nouvelle est d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy
propose qu'à chaque norme
supplémentaires que l'on ajoute
également repris nulle et enfin
troisièmement sur têt ironise normatif
je vous raconte mon expérience
personnelle pendant la campagne des
élections régionales j'étais notamment
sur une exploitation dans ma région en
auvergne d'élevage de volailles la
volaille pour avoir le label en france
il faut avoir 12
12 c'est sa douce non pas 12 critères et
12 poulet par mètre carré se taire et la
france c'est 12 pendant le label la
france a imposé que ça soit on c'est à
dire qu'à la norme
la france a rajouté une autre non ça ça
doit être terminée mais ça te fait
qu'est-ce qui est le plus grave
aujourd'hui pour l'europe qui ont dit au
bord de l'explosion est ce que c'est la
crise des réfugiés ou est ce que c'est
la menace de l'angleterre qui menacent
de quitter l'europe la crise des
réfugiés est dramatique
le chiffre exact c'est un million huit
cent mille franchissement irrégulier sur
l'année 2015
je vous rappelle que c'était 278 milles
en 2014
ça vous laisse imaginer la progression
de la pression maintenant pour le
royaume uni
il faut essayer d'analyser les choses
savent là aussi avec sérénité
je pense que le référendum est une
chance et que le départ sur une
malchance
à lorient il ya des enchantements
européen dans tous les pays de l'union
aujourd'hui alors je reviens à la
question initiale est ce que l'union
aujourd'hui c'est ne trouve pas les
solutions à toutes ces crises qu'on
évoque jo sa survie l'union européenne
est incontestablement menacé dans sa
forme actuelle
incontestablement menacée c'est pour ça
que elle doit évoluer
merci c'est comme le dans le film du
guépard voyez à moitié si il faut que
tout change pour que tout change mais ça
c'est rien ne change
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
brice hortefeux merci michael merci à
tous bon soir et a très vite
vos rendez vous avec public sénat
on en parle avec nous invité ce soir
est ce que ça vous a surpris l'ampleur
de cette victoire il a rebattu les
cartes du gouvernement à quinze mois de
la présidentielle
écoutez le chef de l'état on va plus
loin ces deux moments privilégiés du
débat et de l' échange sur public sénat
avec sonia mabrouk et paul bouffard 90
minutes en direct du lundi au jeudi
pour découvrir débattre et décrypter
l'actualité on va plus loin
du lundi au jeudi à 22h sur public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans la matinale
d'infos de public sénat et de sud radio
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
suis pas nostalgique de la france
d'avant je suis en plein d'espérance de
la france d'après on rejoue en
permanence balladur chirac on essaie de
refaire la même pièce c'est pas sain et
puis les gens surtout ac il ya toujours
en politique nous décision à prendre
parce qu'à un moment il n'y a que des
mauvaises solutions des difficultés donc
moi je préfère assumer cela et symbole
ça compte en politique c'est même majeur
sur les questions